[Music]
hello everybody
your eyes are not deceiving you the
daily Deni is live today with the one
and only I don't rip on I mean come on
what a day what a life what a day I mean
I'm so excited you're here I'm so
excited to be here well listen it is
around 10:30 a.m. over here in Los
Angeles which means it's brunch time
which means mimosa time should we do it
yeah I feel like we should have this
conversation over Moses guys Adam will
be taking your fan questions so send
them over in the comments section below
and we'll get as many as we can all
right here we go
I did it okay listen I'm gonna brunching
but I'm bad at the champagne thing so
I'm glad that wasn't as long as somebody
I was like too afraid to do it myself I
was like as long as this is a total
disaster okay here we go
um do you love brunch thank you them of
course you do I mean come on it's the
best day you know why because thank you
it's uh you can drink in the morning and
it really goes into the evening don't
you think yeah brunch is sort of like a
whole day oh okay all right well cheers
to you I mean on a amazing job at the
Olympics I'm for being here today thank
you Oh delicious again if you guys are
just joining us we're sitting down with
Adam respond send us your fan questions
we'll get them here to the iPad but I
mean there is so much to talk to you
about Adam there's a lot going on with
you know I mean first of all why don't
you describe to me the last couple
months for you like how does it feel um
the last couple of months have been like
a total whirlwind yeah at first you know
it's just training and training and
training getting ready for the Olympics
getting ready to just know that it's
gonna be a crazy experience but be able
to like go and focus and then post
Olympics it's just been even more wild
yeah I've been working every single day
I've been really doing everything I can
to just take advantage of this whole
crazy and awesome opportunity and you
know just celebrate with it I mean
that's why we have the most I think it's
time for you have a break you said you
haven't really had a real break since
the Olympics right I haven't and that's
why I was like 10:30 in Burbank would be
the best time for me
to really let go and let loose I thought
so I was like this is the place for you
to just finally be yourself I've been so
bottled up recently
do we know who you really really are yet
yeah it's been really challenging for me
to really not be myself no really hard
yeah I mean it goes without saying you
capture the hearts of America at the
Olympics and especially me I mean I was
so stoked in fact I want to show you
something it is a clip of me watching
your free skate oh my god I don't par
which by the way you're like looking
shiny shimmering splendid and I'm just
cleaning out take a look
never happen
permit Adam
what can I say I am a fan I mean what's
not pictured in that video is I'm at a
bar there are a ton of people watching
you on the screens like it's the Super
Bowl
really I mean how surreal is that that
is surreal I mean yeah I mean like I'm
at a bar
ya know exactly on everything in a
costume I know yeah people were cheering
you want I mean it's been really magical
to watch and you know what I find so
fascinating is that your storyline at
the Olympics could have easily been a
political one it has easily been about
you standing up against Mike Pence could
have easily been about you being the
first openly gay athlete to compete at
the Olympics but you like transcended
the moment and it became so much more I
mean is that how you feel well I mean I
had so much going on with a lot of
different like headlines that could have
taken over but more than anything I went
there and I was like I want this to be
my experience and I want this to be
something I'll look back on and it won't
be tagged with something else
and you know I think that you know being
the first openly gay Olympian from the
United States in the Winter Games is
incredible but I mean like I don't get
celebrated for being gay in my house or
at home and I barely think about it I
mean I'm exhausting enough as it is
so it's never been a big deal for me I
just you know I had so many ups and
downs of getting to the Olympics over
like the past 10 years of my career then
I worked so hard to get there that when
I got there I was like I'm just gonna
have the best time that I absolutely can
and I'm gonna work really hard so that I
can also back up you know having a big
personality with something that's also
as you know the best that I can do
absolutely you really did go there to
live your best life I feel like you at
the Olympics is like us at the Olympics
you know you got a you got to enjoy it I
brought everybody with you really really
did I mean that and looking back at your
experience in Pyeongchang
how do you think you'll be remembered
well I think I'll be remembered oh yeah
how baby I don't know I think different
people will have different memories
but I know that my own memory of the
Olympics will be that I was in the best
shape of my life
I had the best time I met so many
incredible people and a lot of people
say that you know they wait for that
Olympic moment where they have those
perfect skates and that's what they wait
for and I think for me I've always been
waiting for that moment after after
because this is the stuff that I like
love to do I love chatting with people I
love I mean you really are owning the
moment which is pretty amazing to watch
you know we learned that you had a skate
and a performance prepared for the
closing ceremonies but you didn't
ultimately get to perform right that
included your own cover of Rihanna's
diamonds yeah I mean that's a scene
since we didn't ever get to see it will
we see it ever will you perform it
somewhere else yes I think I will and
you know there have been a few like
exhibitions where usually we have an
exhibition that's right after the
competition and we're usually exhausted
from the competent oh come on
and so there were a few times this year
where I performed the song live at the
exhibition like while I was instead of
like skating and they were like oh
that's so cool and I was like I'm just
taking a break I didn't know you could
sing though like what would we on I
think under cover of diamonds um I don't
know
I'm sure Rihanna thinks so many things I
think she's like done with you probably
I mean maybe I don't know yeah I don't
know I don't want to put words in reason
our not too bad girl really no not today
speaking of bad girl let's cut to the
chase how ratchet did you get in
Pyeongchang I did so here's the thing I
put on a huge show that I'm like trash
which I am but I don't really ever get
that messy okay being trash and being
messy are two different things
amen you better preach why'd you look at
me when you said that okay because the
lights are bright and I can't say
anything is because I took a sip while
they're on the clock
let me live my life
would you consider Messi I really like
oh no I mean I was wondering like how
turned up did you get not very I mean I
was so busy that like my turn up was
like when I was doing an interview and
I'd be like Mike Tirico I need a zani
that was my turn up that's true
now speaking of turn up you've got so
many celebrity fans who just get like
route up about you you had a lot of
run-ins recently I mean these celebs
like Mandy Moore Reese Witherspoon are
legitimately starstruck by you I mean is
that surreal for you yeah it is surreal
and you know what I'm not really one to
get starstruck myself because you know I
know the kind of work that it takes to
get you know to a place where you're
achieving your dreams you're living your
best life and you know meeting Mandy and
meeting Reese they've they're just so
genuine mm-hmm and I think that you
really need to be genuine to like
achieve great things so meeting them is
so easy because they're just you know
really they've all yeah they're real
people and they've all been like so
genuinely kind so cool they've been
watching you too I know that's I think
that's the most surreal part of all of
that is that they watched me skate at
the Olympics and they're genuinely
interested in meeting me and yeah it's
been it's been incredible I do want to
share a story though okay this isn't
really like a shady like Adam reponse Oh
Sassie story it's like a nice one okay I
have some nice stories so when I was so
excited to meet Rhys because we had been
talking a little bit like back and forth
of trying to find a time when we could
meet and we finally found out we were
going to be on The Late Show with
Colbert at the on the same night fate
really I mean I mean the stars aligned
they did you know they did destiny as
some would say it was meant to be um so
we met and during the so we had a great
like interaction is so nice to meet her
in person
and but what really like blew me away
was we cut to commercial and she was
like I have to run to the wrinkle and
time premiere but if you have family
here I would
love to to meet them and I said yeah I
mean they're just sitting in the yeah
they're sitting in the in the in my
dressing room okay so it's like they're
just sitting in the dressing room like
they're just hanging out like you can
you're like you can do whatever you want
girl and she's like okay and she's like
it's so great meeting you I'm like I
have to run and I was like okay so I
started taping but while I was taping
while she was getting ready to go to the
premiere she went and she met um you
know my two friends well two friends I
had one friend and my brother but like
my brother's my friends and she met them
and she had a like chat with them and
took pictures with them and then ran out
and you it was just like that that
really blew me away that she really
didn't need to do that but I think that
really I know she's really we love her
that's right you know what
you're giving her a run for her money as
America's Sweetheart you know that I
mean we're both running yeah
which will keep us in great shape I love
it we'll do that now here's more proof
of your celebrity status did you hear
about this man who's dressed as Elsa who
say yesterday so in case you guys missed
it there was a man in Boston dressed as
Elsa from frozen who literally helped
this police vehicle out of snow he was
wearing that costume just to be funny
but then it really came to someone help
yeah so anyways this went completely
viral and he said if this is his 15
minutes of fame he wants to leverage it
to meet you I consider that a leverage
like I don't know if he's watching right
now but if he is do you have a message
for him other camera they say not all
heroes wear capes but sometimes they do
that's it you're welcome
kind stranger I love that I think he
lives in like Boston it's in Boston
yeah I don't do snow so no I don't
either
yeah they don't do that well let it go
okay someone else you met recently oh my
god yeah dad um you finally got to meet
Sally Field son when you were being
awarded the visibility weren't at the
HRC gala ah a lot of people trying to
ship you among them his mother Sally
Field what was that meeting like I mean
it was nice to meet him
and in first thing while I was at the
dinner somebody came up to me they're
like Sally Fields son is here and I was
like well I should I have to meet him so
they introduced me and he I go over to
him and he's sitting in the chair he's
like I'm so sorry and I was like don't
be sorry at all embarrassed yeah he was
embarrassed but he's like his Sam is
like super nice and I am getting ready
for like a stars a nice tour so we start
in April and in May and we're coming to
LA May 12th will be like at the Honda
Center in Anaheim so I was like I'm
inviting you and your mom and any of
your friends that want to come so they
have tickets they're gonna come to this
oh my god I was gonna ask if there was
plans to hang out but this is perfect
you're giving them like VIP access to
stars on ice with Sally Field Oscar
where Sally Field is gonna watch you on
the ice that's pretty amazing I know so
like where there feels like a Sally
Field gonna be your future mother-in-law
I think there are some like friendship
feel okay all right I just want to I
want to know what the inside of Sally
Fields house looks like so you gotta let
me know okay I well imagine there's a
room with like for two Oscars The Flying
Nun habit and yeah Doubtfire prosthetics
or something well you know what if I
ever make it there can I come I will
call you yes yeah thank you perfect I'll
pin the location can you yeah I love it
okay guys so uh stars on ice you
mentioned that that's coming up what are
you looking forward to hitting the road
with all your fellow skaters um you know
what I'm really looking forward to like
hanging out with my friends and having
that like tour experience it'll be
really fun
tbh I haven't skated that much since the
Olympics
so I'm oh yeah so after just a little
drink I'm gonna I'm actually going to
the rink after yes I'm having this for
like the vitamins yeah exactly
stay healthy yeah emergency yes it's
like I need the vitamin C so I don't get
scurvy yep that's what the mimosa is for
I think it's on this bottle yeah this is
right there AHA this one a day prevent
scurvy what mimosa a day some lot of fan
love is coming in for you right now so
much love coming through David says
you're a force to reckon with I admire
you and Debbie says you were the best
part of the Olympics
Debbie I agree with you David I agree
with Debbie you're not wrong I was
watching you up at the Olympics I
thought do I love the Olympics now I was
skating in them and I was like do I love
that so I was like I think I'm a sports
fan now um okay we got to get down to
business let's do it so there has been a
lot of speculation that you'll be
joining Dancing with the Stars and he
kind of fueled it with this post at
Debbie Allen Dance Academy a lot of fans
were going crazy about it so can you set
the record straight right now are you
doing the all athletes season of Dancing
with the Stars well I think it would be
a great opportunity and it would be
really fun I've always wanted to learn
how to dance because I'm just been like
a solo act like a one-man show but I was
actually at the Debbie Allen Dance
Academy yesterday I was working with
Travis wall getting ready for stars and
ice okay
so unrelated sure okay so unrelated nice
pivot will tell me this have you been
approached to do it I would think that
like it would be like such as the
Americas and such as I was not expecting
that but that's really good Miss Teen
USA that was really really good okay oh
here I have some follow-ups um if you
could do it mm-hmm would it work in with
your stars on ice schedule because I
know a lot of fans were speculating that
you wouldn't be able to do it because of
the schedules kind of conflict I mean
could you make it both work nor money
who did the show was in the middle of a
world tour you know so hypothetically
speaking would you slip it into your
schedule to make it work you know it
would be a crazy schedule
it is like the the dates are all going
on during the Stars on Ice tour so would
be a lot of traveling and like I said
I've never danced with a partner before
yeah how are your dancing skills like I
think they're more like solo skills yeah
yeah usually so like I said I don't get
messy very often and I'll tell you why
usually I'm pretty like crazy person
really like outgoing kind of like loud
kind of loud I'm loud you yeah
and so then like when I go out I'll just
start dancing a little bit and I'll be
having a good time and usually people
think like oh she's crazy
which they're not wrong but um it
usually looks like I'm gonna like hurt
myself and that's by myself right I
don't know what kind of insurance I'm
just curious to see what you'd be like
with the skates off you know you're so
graceful on them and on the ice which is
really difficult to do but then on the
ballroom floor that's a different story
yeah it's totally different yeah so um
do you have like a dream partner you
would want to be paired with if you
could ever do Dancing with the Stars I
mean like I do love the girls on the
show I I think any choice would be great
I think like if I did have the chance to
do the show
I mean I always loved watching like
Lindsay or Whitney or Jenna like they're
they're great they're amazing you know
your choreographer Benji Schwimmer the
choreograph your skate right at the
Olympics yes he actually told us he
would be down and it would be awesome if
you guys were partners I mean how do you
feel about that do you feel like it's
time for Dancing with the Stars have
like a same-sex partner or pairing for
the show I mean I think it would be
pretty cool
I've known Benji for a really long time
and he has like I've known Benji from
maybe like 6 years already
and he's done a lot of my like
choreography on the ice so if we ever
danced together I mean I would
definitely feel pretty comfortable
because we've known each other for a
really long time it would be a lot of
fun yeah so yeah why not right I think
it's time it'll be really awesome
especially to see you and Benji knowing
your guys's history and now that he
would actually kind of be the forefront
with you you know you're in that
experience I think would be really cool
um something else I want to ask you
about is when you were on Ellen she
loves you obsessed with you as I am
right now in this moment but she also
mentioned that in this moment I mean
happy limpet ran his moment let me tell
you in person he's just as lovely as he
is on the TV screen looking like Elsa on
that ice amazing ah no but Ellen did say
she would love to work with you um there
were some reports that you guys are
actually working on something not
scripted for the show is that true you
know when I was at the show she was like
I would love to do something with you
like and I was like Ellen of course yes
so you know I think we're kind of just
talking a little bit back and forth
about what that might be I would love to
I mean I like she's one of my heroes and
one of my idols one of my style
inspirations like I'd wear all of her
clothes yeah you actually when I came in
here thank you
I was like Ellen I look like Ellen yeah
oh that is the best compliment I've ever
received seriously she really is my
style inspiration Ellen
send me your clothes what would would
you want to do with Ellen like what with
a dream project and collaboration be
with her in particular I don't know I
think that like anything that I do in
the future I want I want to do something
where I can really be myself because I
feel like that's where I I mean you know
I don't know sky's the limit
it is the sky is the limit especially
like everything that's going on right
now I feel like there are so many open
doors and I'm trying to walk through
each one of them and take advantage of
every opportunity to kind of see what I
want to do next like what do I really
like what's a format I like because I
definitely see myself staying in the
entertainment world I'm gonna
entertained I mean clearly come on you
get him back in the spotlight I mean
what is on your post skating bucket list
you mentioned there's a lot of
opportunities coming your way what do
you want to do next I don't know and I
think that's the hardest question right
now but you have choices I do have
choices I think that in the past skating
was so it was so easy for me to see what
was next
it's like you know make a plan I know
where I want to go enjoy that process
and right now it just seems so crazy
because I'm trying to take advantage of
everything so every day it's a little
something different and I don't really
know what's next I have a bunch of
things coming up sure that are next and
that I'm so excited to be a part of but
what's my next job what's my next
career right right I don't really know
what that is we'll be watching I can't
wait to find out I think you also have a
future of fashion I saw you at the
Oscars
in that mosquito right it was yeah in
fact Carmen says she is currently or he
is currently seeking leather harness to
wear for our future selfie
she's gonna take a selfie and harness
with ya how do you feel about that I
feel really good about it
mm-hmm I have some rapid fire and some
more fan questions that we collected
earlier for you ah do you myrrh I still
get in and out and hang out so when we
went to the Oscars we went to the Vanity
Fair party right after and this is
something that I had heard but didn't
know was true until I saw the truth in
front of my eyes and then I was living
the truth and the truth is that at the
Vanity Fair party they are walking
around with like you know you know you
go to the fancy party and they're like a
more dirt right on a silver platter yes
yeah at the Vanity Fair party it's in
and out burgers I love them yeah
obsessed yeah I love her because you
have that night like two - okay yeah
solid fries they didn't have fries
blasphemy Vanity Fair I know I love some
animal style fries I dip my fries in
this sauce oh you do saucy I ladder my
fries with the sauce okay yeah mimosas
in in and out sounds like we have a
future hangout coming up I agree
great what shows do you watch so one of
my favorite shows is RuPaul's Drag Race
I'm so glad you say that tonight is the
finale I know I'm scared who you rootin
for I think well I mean I really love
all of the girls I know that's so like
blase but okay okay I'm gonna tell you
something you tell me I really
capitalized on Kennedy Davenport's like
monologue from season seven when she was
wearing that like wow
fire alpha when she said like after a
long night hookin trade didn't like this
session and then in that moment I was
like that's my president
woman you know what I mean no absolutely
I love Trixie I mean but and shangela
has been so funny I'm just such a huge
huge fan could we ever see you as a
guest judge on the show I mean I would
love to do that I have a lot to say I
believe that yeah I believe it as well
house rule reached out yeah I'd be
surprised if you didn't well I think
that it would be so much it would be
really honestly I read I drink more no I
would die if I were able to do the show
um I mean everybody's asked like are you
gonna do the show would you be a guest
judge and I'm like I would literally run
into the middle of the 101 right now if
I were able to make that happen
don't do that we need you don't do that
please do I need that job do you know
what you do need that job oh you'd be
perfect for that job and I have a
feeling that job is coming up okay um
here's an important question what does
Shawn Mendes smell like like a boy I
don't know it's like I had been already
eaten like an in-n-out burger so I
didn't get a real like sense of the
whole experience so you're still
smelling grilled onions yeah and like
special sauce and like I prefer that
over Shawn Mendes personally but I don't
know I know
I agree no we're doing to know that that
special sauce thanks I'm in and out okay
shag marry kill you ready yeah Shawn
Mendes Harry Styles Nick Jonas why oh my
god cuz that's not right it's brunch
we're having fun there's mimosas I want
to know shag marry kill alright and
Shawn Mendes Harry Styles are you gonna
answer it - or is this okay I will
answer if you answer okay Mary oh my god
this is like so hard I didn't know I was
gonna answer this either so now I'm like
freaking out okay dudududu dude no oh
yeah okay okay can i I think
I know Mary Shawn Mendes shagged Harry
Styles kill Nick Jonas that's not okay
since you answered I am gonna go Nick
deserves more than that and better than
that does which is why I'm gonna shag
him I'm gonna shag Nick Jonas I'm gonna
marry Oh God
I don't want the one Directioners to
come at me but I think I'm gonna marry
Shawn Mendes and kill Harry Styles ah
I'm sorry we just live two different
lives I just can't see ya alive and dad
I apologize I apologize that's not a
fair one no I'm horrible I regret asking
you because then I had a responder marry
off three but like good divorce but in
whatever order okay we're running out of
time here but I do a speaking of Harry
actually I want to get your input on
this so fans thinks fans thought that
Harry was addressing his sexuality and
his new song medicine and I know you
tweeted about it what were your thoughts
about that you know what I think that
he's been such like an ally of like the
LGBTQ community and pretty much like
unabashedly himself and his like career
and you know he's like a young kid who's
like our age were young and we're hip
and um you know I think he's just sort
of like on a journey and he doesn't
really care and I hope that like young
kids can like look to that and they can
really you know go on a journey of like
self-discovery and learn who they are
and I think he's sending a really
positive message and then when I saw
that I dropped my phone I threw it and I
said where the hell is he so you think
you have a chance now with Harry
probably not maybe you know you never
know cast your spell like you cast your
spell on all of America right you know
I'm just trying to find the right spell
I've been going to the gym and my chess
where I'm like
okay okay quick fan questions before you
wrap up gosh Kista forever actually I
can we have time right um okay Sarah
says hi Adam are you dating anyone right
now I am NOT yeah open to suggestions
well you told us that the Oscars that if
you got a job and you go to the gym to
hit you up
is that still ring true is there any
other qualifications you want to add to
that shortlist no no cool I mean am I
wrong no not at all are you kidding yeah
yeah you know what I'm really I'm
looking for somebody who has like a lot
of passion and is funny okay okay I'm
doing that cuz like my legs are sore too
alright so that you try to run out of
here right now
anyways you know let's quick quick quick
quick quick I mean what do you want i
your fans actually everyone was watching
right now who watched you got the
olympics who are watching following your
story now who you've inspired seriously
what do you want tell them um you know
it's been crazy
I think what's been crazy is that I
wasn't expecting so many people to reach
out to me and tell me that they are they
still struggle just being themselves I
think coming out is a crazy experience
like but for me it was like the best
thing that I ever did it was the most
liberating experience and I don't think
coming out is like completely limited to
straight people or I'm sorry gay people
I think it's sort of for everybody and
it's a term for accepting who you are
and sharing that with the world and I
think everybody needs to have like a
coming-out and because that's when you
really like own who you are no matter
what that is and for me it was so
important and it changed the whole
course of my life I just became so much
more confident in like decisions I was
making like when I would go to the rink
I would have a plan of what I wanted to
do with my coach I felt confident to
make choices in my life where I was like
you know what I can do this I can sign
that lease
on that 2013 Jetta mm-hmm and and I'll
be okay I know I can do it like I felt
strong and powerful from that experience
and I think that I was really lucky to
speak at the HRC gala dinner and here in
Los Angeles because I really just want
you know all kids no matter like their
age or where they come from or their
background or anything like that to you
know if you own who you are and you set
goals and you work hard you can really
do anything absolutely I mean I
convinced people on The Today Show to
call me America's Sweetheart if I could
do that literally there are no rules
I that's what I call you know I refer to
you as America's Sweetheart you got us
all doing that it's that spell again I
know but the spell is the fact that you
truly are an inspiration to so many
people out there especially young LGBTQ
youth out there um you know as you put
it the greatest gift is to know who you
are and to own it and you do it
beautifully so congrats on everything
thank you for being here today seriously
on and thank you guys so much for
watching and sending your questions
stars on ice hits the road on April 6
they're coming to a city near you so go
check them out we're gonna finish these
but make sure you guys come back
tomorrow for another daily denne cheers
to you here's the interest I mean we all
just to us cheers to us oh what a way to
end guys goodbye thanks guys
[Music]